There is a messed up set of incentives
that's baked into the
K-12 public school system,
where they get your money
regardless of whether they
open their doors for business.
So teachers unions had an incentive
to keep their doors closed.
Corey DeAngelis,
the Reason Foundation's
director of school choice,
has been tracking the
impact of the pandemic
on education policy.
He's found that a
growing number of parents
are leaving traditional public schools
and looking to take their
education dollars with them.
At the same time,
there's growing frustration
with teachers unions
for their continued
opposition to reopening,
despite mounting evidence that schools
aren't a significant source of infection.
Why was it okay for the
private schools to reopen
but not the public schools?
The public schools in
some places were saying
that we can't open for
in-person instruction
because it's too dangerous.
But then they were reopening the same
physical school buildings
for in-person childcare activities.
DeAngelis says that unions have made
a host of ridiculous demands as conditions
for returning to work.
But they started lumping in
all of these political demands
in their calls to reopen schools.
So for example, one of
the first teachers unions
to do this was the Los
Angeles teachers union.
They wanted to defund the police,
they wanted Medicare for all,
and all these other political
goals that didn't seem
like they had a lot to do
with the reopening of schools.
With public schools struggling
to provide quality online education,
many parents attempted
to transfer their kids
into virtual charter schools,
taking their education dollars with them.
DeAngelis says teachers
unions turn to lawmakers
to stop the outflow.
The Oregon Education Association
lobbied to the government
to make it illegal
for families to switch to
schools in this time of need.
And you saw similar actions in places
like California and Pennsylvania,
where the money wouldn't follow the child
to the charter schools.
This was an act that
protected the monopoly
at the expense of thousands of families.
As a result of slow and incompetent
rollouts of distance learning,
students around the country are failing
at much higher rates.
So for example, in my area,
Fairfax County public schools,
the rates of students
who have been failing
two or more classes has increased by 83%
since last year.
There's been a nationwide study
on this by McKinsey and Company,
and they've estimated
that students have lost
between one and three months
of education this year,
and they've seen that there
have been inequities as well.
For disadvantaged groups of students,
they've lost more months of learning
than more advantaged groups of students.
The silver lining is that
there's growing recognition
that traditional education
funding is deeply flawed,
and that money needs to follow the child.
The latest national survey from Gallup
estimates that traditional
public schools will lose
about seven percentage points
of their student population
this school year.
More and more people
are starting to realize
these closed buildings are continuing
to get their children's education dollars.
while they're scrambling,
and none of that money's following them
to pay for private school
tuition and fees out of pocket,
or to help cover the costs
associated with a home-based education.
86% of families now support the concept
of education savings accounts,
or what I like to call "funding students
as opposed to systems."
I've been tracking about 14 states now,
this year, in January,
that have had legislators
introduce bills to fund
students as opposed to systems.
So states like New Hampshire,
Utah has a particular
bill that's interesting.
Kansas and Kentucky
Arizona has a bill to expand
their already existing
school choice program.
You have Nebraska, you have Iowa.
Florida has a bill to restructure
all of their vouchers.
A lot of people are figuring out
that there's no good
reason to fund institutions
when we can fund students
directly instead.